- Are you vegan?
Good.
(classical music)
- I don't think I've ever touched
a single vegan food in my life,
except like by accident.
- I usually do like vegan food.
- I'm skeptical of these vegan desserts.
- This is the vegan glazed doughnut,
but I hear the word doughnut,
and I'm on board.
- It looks like a regular doughnut.
- It doesn't smell like a doughnut.
It smells like a lemon square.
- Oh, this is good.
- That's terrible.
- This kinda tastes
like fruit loops to me.
- If I was having this and
you told me it was vegan,
I would not believe it.
- Yes for the vegan doughnut.
I'm liking it.
- Tofu vegan cheesecake? (disgusted noise)
- It's more wiggly than
regular cheesecake.
- It does not smell
like cheesecake at all.
- Mmm.
- No.
- It's really gritty.
- The texture's awful.
- Or like soaked, mushy bread.
- I could not describe to
you what this taste is,
I can just tell you that
it's working for me.
- It's like eating a giant tofu
with a lotta sugar in it.
- Why call it cheesecake
if it's not gonna taste like cheesecake?
- The more that I have
it, the more I like it.
- Vegan snickerdoodle.
I'm feeling good about
these snickerdoodles.
- These are so soft.
- They look like rocks.
- All vegan desserts look like dirt.
- Oh yeah.
- It tastes gingery.
- These win.
- It's mushy. It's just
not working for me.
- Cookies should crumble
and I can mold this into any shape I want.
- Vegan cherry ice cream.
It looks like a regular
piece of ice cream,
except it's really hard.
- There are little pieces
of chocolate in it.
- Smells like ice cream.
- It's really good.
- That sucks.
- That's super fruity.
- It tastes kinda like cherry
flavored Bubblicious gum.
- Knowing that it's vegan,
it tastes fresher.
- Here's the thing,
I would probably eat any
dessert no matter what.
- Raw vegan brownie.
Looks like a brownie with seeds in it.
- It looks like a granola bar.
- Nothing about this
screams brownie to me.
- That's delicious.
- I don't like it.
- It's definitely chocolatey.
- It tastes exactly like a Cliff bar.
- Mushy texture seems to be
a running theme through vegan desserts.
- I would eat it again.
- I wish vegan foods
would just stop trying
to imitate non vegan foods.
Just be yourself.
Be whatever it is that you are.
(classical music)